Welcome back everyone this is going to be
my new Thor 4 love and thunder video all about
Loki there's a bunch of video Tom Hiddleston explaining
where Loki fits into all this where Thor love
and thunder sort of intersects with the Loki
series.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand-new to the channel and doing
videos for all the Loki episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything were
doing a Disney plus giveaway for memberships
to all you do to enter is be subscriber and let me  know
what other kind of Thor Easter eggs you want
to see during the Loki series we've already
seen a couple Thor Easter egg that I talked
about during my episode videos so post links
for those done in the description there will
be more Thor Easter eggs throughout the future
episodes to because a lot of the Loki series
plays on the Thor movies because of jumping
through time.
So the parenting a lot of moments from the
avengers films from the Thor film so that's
why there's so many Thor Easter eggs, but
Tom Hiddleston was just talking about what's
going on between the events of Thor love and
thunder.
And what's going on with Thor in present day
in general while this new Loki the variant
Loki is going around on missions with the
time variance authority in what they are relationship
is like like what this new Loki's relationship
is like with this version of Thor the main
version of Thor.
So this is the clip of him talking about that
Thor is that the thing I why love about this
universes like Thor and Loki started together
and they been like they ran on parallel tracks
for a while and and now they kind of on different
tracks but the sale aware of each other.
That's the thing this to both Thor Loki that
you know that they exist in the minds of each
it was really it's an interesting to think
about like you doing this series, I would
email Chris and because I it was impossible
not to take.
I carry him in mind conceit you know he's
been on this journey with me, but he's got
his on his own new family is in love and thunder
and and I think I'm pretty sure Thor has his own
challenges now, different challenges
So what he means when he says that his variant Loki
and Thor are on different tracks now but they're
still aware of each other.
And they still think about each other and
that Thor has his new family now Loki has
his own new family is see that one, Loki during
the series, at a certain point does eventually
learn what's happened with the rest of the
events of Avengers endgame.
Like during his trial with Judge Renslayer
at the beginning of episode one he knew that
the avengers had time traveled back into the
past to steal the infinity stones.
Not because anyone told him it as we learned
through his conversation because he sensed
the future versions were there in the moment.
Like he detected Tony Stark's stench the Axe
body spray joke that they made during endgame.
But, the thing is is this Loki doesn't know about
anything that happened after that moment because
he portaled that with the Tesseract and then
was immediately arrested by the TVA in your
seeing him in this moment right here of using
about his life unfolding in a linear fashion
the avengers are still probably in the middle
of their big final battle with thanos right
now technically so he wouldn't find out about
the final battle with thanos and Thor going
off with the guardians of the galaxy till
little bit later, but because the TVA has
complete files on the lives of everyone in
existence everyone who's ever lived or ever will live.
That's how he would learn about most of what's
happened most of what you see him doing here
reading through all these files with Mobeus
is mostly specific to the Loki variants that
they're hunting down like the very dangerous
Loki that we believe to be female Loki lady loki.
How ever you want to think about her this is the
strongest theory about who there technically
trying to chase down out the most dangerous
version I think that's a big misdirected will
learn more about that in the next couple of
episodes for the TVA would also have a file
on Thor the main version of Thor 616
Thor however you want to think about them
that Loki could read while this is going on
and that's how he finds out what happens to him.
And how he knows what's going on with him during
the events of Thor love and thunder.
And because of the way they're jumping around
the timeline backwards and forwards the events
of Loki kind of overlap with the events of
Thor for but if you really want to get technical about it.
The way that marvel talks about at the actors
the producers Kevin vitae the events of the
Loki series are meant to create these big
ripples in the multiverse in the timeline
that affect all the marvel movies that are
coming after, so it's meant to set up doctor
strange 2 multiverse of madness they also
confirmed this can have some influence on
the plot of Spider-Man no way home just because
of all the implied multiverse elements in
that movie or spider verse because were talk
about Spider-Man characters in Thor love and
thunder is meant to take place after the events
of doctor strange 2 so technically the events
of the Loki series kind of take place before
the events of Thor love and thunder is easy
get twisted around when you talk about where
this Loki is right now in the timeline when
he's inside the time keepers citadel.
When he's in the citadel here because it was
created in the distant future technically
he is in the distant future, but really it
exists in a pocket dimension outside of the
normal the sacred timeline in they're jumping
backwards and forwards inside the main timeline
in these alternate timelines.
So some of the series takes place before during
and some of it after the events of Thor love and thunder.
And when he says that Thor is aware of Loki
right now he didn't give away big spoilers
as to how Thor finds out about this new Loki
very but it sounds like between the ending
of the Loki series, Loki season two in the
end of Thor love and thunder.
At some point Thor is gains a deeper understanding
of the multiverse and understands how even
though his Loki died and isn't coming back.
There is a Loki who is very much like him
in still out there who's alive with the idea
that they'll eventually have some awkward
run in His Way, Taika Waititi talked about
he started discussing the idea of doing a
Thor five movie if you can believe it after
love and thunder.
Just to say that he was open to the idea but
he's got so many other movies that he's working
on so many other TV series.
That ifthey did Thor 5.
It wouldn't happen till like way after Avengers
five.
Which is already a long ways off in the future.
But that's why Chris Hemsworth said a long
time ago that Thor love and thunder was not
the end of his Thor in the Marvel cinematic
universe and he was excited to continue playing
Thor Tom Hiddleston also kindest of the same
thing to he said he be happy to be playing
Loki in another 10 years but you probably
saw a lot of people talking about Loki inside
Thor love and thunder this past week because
there were some comic the Tom Hiddleston made
the implied that he wasn't a big character
in the film and people just took that's me
that he was in the movie it all.
This is actually what Tom Hiddleston said
about he said that we talked about the Thor
movies is a family saga the Odinson saga
and the diametric opposition between Thor
and Loki and duality and antagonism being
a book that perhaps should remain closed for
the moment we've explored about as much as
we can about these two brothers weenies when
he says that is that he Chris Hemsworth just
felt like they'd of so many Thor versus Loki
stories about their relationship is brothers
that they were just taking a break on it for
a hot minute in Thor love and thunder.
That doesn't mean the movie won't reference
Loki at all.
It just means that he's not a main character
like he's been in the Thor movies up to this point.
And while they were working on Thor love and
thunder.
Tom Hiddleston was mostly focused on developing
his new variant version of Loki in the Loki
series but once that's done, the next time
they do have a Thor Loki story.
These have a completely different story to
tell like it would be so much about them being
brothers to be completely different dynamic.
And as for Chris Hemsworth actually cameo
being on the Loki series I have a feeling
it's going to be a Benedict Cumberbatch Wandavision
situation where they probably talked about
it a because of all the virus lockdowns and
travel restrictions it sounds like Chris Hemsworth
probably did not film any new scenes for the
Loki series, the answer is you suck and look
forward to sucking again in season to and
forward to collecting yes more trophies but
they Morty had several Thor Easter eggs there
be more Thor Easter eggs in future episodes
such as a similar situation with Benedict
Cumberbatch's deleted scenes from the Wandavision series.
The funny thing about that too.
Is it all the Benedict Cumberbatch Wandavision
deleted scenes are also what connected to
the Loki series because of all the Nexus talk
all the commercials, the next step Doctor
strange was meant to show up as part of that
arc during Wandavision in all the Nexus talk
scarlet witch as a nexus all the talk of nexus
events on the Loki series is what binds that
to doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness
so your starting to see how all these things are connected
and Marvel phase 4 now when Tom Hiddleston
was talking about Thor's new family that he's
got in Thor love and thunder obviously he was referring
to the guardians of the galaxy or the asgardians
of the galaxy.
Chris Hemsworth actually just posted this
new picture of them from the set a couple
days ago to celebrate Chris Evan's birthday.
A lot of you were asking what this necklace
Chris Pratt's star lord is wearing.
It looks like something that belonged to yondu.
Because the whole idea here is that he's wearing
yondu jacket in the movie, but he's modified
it with those metal pieces, the shoulder plates
and the gauntlets the design seems a little
bit like it's inspired by ego the living planets
costume like this new upgraded costume all
the stuff, these wearing his him just showing
his character development, how is dealt with
the trauma over the death of his surrogate
father yondu but also his real father ego
the living planet sways literally and metaphorically
carrying bits of them forward with him.
Tom Hiddleston was also hyping up some of
the other cameo scenes the big cameo scenes
the Loki series.
He wouldn't giveaway his favorite that he
was most excited for but I believe that he
was probably talking about Richard E grants
scenes it was reported early on that he was
supposed to be playing a version of what they
were calling classic Loki like he was an alternate
version of Loki.
It was much older but the version that he
was playing was a much more evil version of
the character in a much more old-school looking
version of the classic comic book character
like a Loki costume with his giant horns.
A lot of you are also asking about that devil
reference to because the director obviously
confirmed it was not meant to be a Mephisto
reference.
It was more of a reference to Loki or the
variant Loki they gave the little boy the gum.
Because when they said who gave you the gum
he pointed to the picture the devil if you
notice the little boys tongue was blue the
tongue of the devil was also blue so just
meant to be a reference to this variant Loki
that there chasing down who we believe to
be is a lady Loki.
But you also notice the picture.
The devil has the giant horns coming out of
his head.
That's meant to be a reference to Loki's horns
Tom Hiddleston did say that the series would
explain why Loki wears that helmets with the
horns on them.
They kind of made a joke about this with Matt
Damon's Loki when he was talking about than
building a statue of him with his giant horns
in outside that theater and Asgard Thor sees
that they actually did build a statue of Loki
with really big horns Tom Hiddleston did talk
about Matt Damon as Loki.
He just as it it was just surreal and completely
weird.
And he was totally cool with it like he walk
on the set one day in Thor Ragnarok and he
was standing there and it was like looking
of fun house mirror but he was also pleasantly
surprised with what they did with the Matt
Damon version of Loki during Thor love and thunder.
Because there bringing him back to do another
fake play, but this time the fake play is
parodying the events of Thor Ragnarok in the
way that Thor Ragnarok splay.
The events of the previous movie, which was
Thor the dark world, but really big stuff
coming up this week my full Loki episode 2
video will post Wednesday I just did a video
about the big Avengers secret wars teaser
and Loki in the doctor strange 2 teaser and
references saws add a link for that at the
end of this and down of the description and
will probably get that big Thor love and thunder
trailer before the end of the year graduations
BunderChowed your the giveaway winner for
my last big marvel video.
Please email me on the about page my channel
so I can get your contact details everyone
click here for that Loki secret wars teaser
and Kang the conqueror explained and click
here for my full Loki episode 1 video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
say hello guys tonight!